foreign
hey I'm Travis Barker and these are my
10 Essentials
[Music]
um we'll start with my wedding ring
I just wanted something really simple I
love silver I love like white gold I
like the just row of pave diamonds it
just matches everything it's awesome
couldn't think of a better ring my
wife's ring is a little more flashy I
don't really like something like too
flashy I like something that I can wear
every day she has like a beautiful band
with a row of diamonds and then she has
a really really kind of like bigger
Diamond that was like our engagement
ring that I proposed her with
these are my drumsticks I don't go
anywhere without these These are
literally in my suitcase next to my
shoes my underwear my t-shirts whatever
I'm bringing sometimes I have like a
practice pad kit that goes everywhere
with me too but no matter what when you
can't get a practice in you can't get a
rehearsal Studio it's drumsticks and a
pillow pillow makes it really hard to
play and there's no bouncing there's no
rebound it's like the perfect situation
when I was in Drumline as a kid they
would always tell us just practice on
pillows because like you would get your
chops would be way better if you played
on pillows these drumsticks are modeled
after sd1 generals like a Vic for a
stick that I grew up playing in concert
band I feel off if I don't have these
with me and I feel off if I haven't like
rehearsed at all during the day I feel
good if it's about an hour like nothing
less than an hour like I'm getting ready
for a show right now like I have a show
tomorrow so I'll just set my timer for
an hour and I'll go through everything I
want to practice and I I go through
drumsticks so fast like I love beat up
sticks ones that I practice with and
I'll even bring them to shows or
rehearse and they break right away which
is kind of a bum out
this is a necklace I love to wear all
the time it's a junior necklace I have
another one that's a little bit bigger
and some of the spikes were missing
because I'd wear it so much when I'm
playing it's like it was rusted and some
of the spikes would fall off so this is
like a new one that I replaced it with
but I still wear the one with several
spikes missing I don't know it's like
the perfect necklace no one has it
either I feel like I've never seen
anyone else wear it it was given to me
someone brought it to me and said do you
love this and I said I actually love
nothing more I bring it everywhere I go
tend to wear it with like when I wear a
suit or something nice so I still feel
like myself it's just like the perfect
accessory
this incense is better than any other
incense it's called incense of the West
and and the the scent is Pinon it
literally smells like a wood burning
fireplace I go everywhere with it it's
burnt throughout my entire house I bring
it on tour with me it's in my dressing
rooms it's in my hotel rooms everyone
that comes to my studio asks can I
please ask you what that smell is and
it's always this they come in these
little sticks people will come and just
leave with a few of these little sticks
I have these little they're kind of like
candle holders they're just like almost
like a plate and I buy this black sand
and you place these instant sticks
inside the sand then when it's like done
burning it almost looks like ashes the
worst is when people come here and they
confuse it for an ashtray there's like
Backwoods and rolling paper everything
in there but yeah the best incense
one of my favorite candles I bring
everywhere it's called concrete after
lightning it's such like a smaller
candle I wish it came in a bigger size
but it lasts so long I've accidentally
left it on for multiple days at a time
and there's still wax left so it doesn't
like burn too quick literally like makes
the entire house smell like this scent
it's one of my favorite scents honestly
it's a little musky but I have a few
candles I go back and forth with and
this is one of them I buy in like bulk
and I bring it everywhere with me this
is the candle rare DS and Durga it's one
of my favorites
this is a collaboration between
a company I have called DTA and I can
never pronounce his name Theory lottery
I just call him Terry and we designed
these about a year ago and they drop in
like the next month or two I had always
loved his glasses and I bought other
frames from him so like the idea is like
when you collaborate with him it's like
you take an existing frame and you make
it yours you freak it you flip it
somehow so the name of this Frame is
called mastermindy but they never made
him in the matte finish we made them in
a black matte finish and did a little
branding and I love really Square kind
of almost like low glasses that I grew
up wearing I don't go anywhere without
them it's my favorite frame my favorite
sunglass every day it's these
this is Barker Wellness two-in-one face
cleanser and mask
so for so long I literally would take a
bar of soap and wash my face I would
take the same lotion I was putting on my
body and I would put it on my face like
I don't know it took years to figure out
like skin care or even like worrying
about like going out in the sun or
wearing sunblock when I was going down
that path I noticed a lot of products
weren't vegan a lot of them you could
find like you know like toxic chemicals
in it so it was really important when I
went on the journey to create Barker
Wellness
to build a void of what was missing for
me and that was like simple skincare
that was like cruelty free non-toxic and
vegan this is unisex but for so many
males I think we're lost and we kind of
kind of like figure it out ourselves and
I think like we all care about it like
we all care if like our Skin's clean or
if we're using like good products and
for me just knowing that I'm using
something where no animals got hurt I'm
stoked
I stayed away from Bluetooth headphones
forever because they said they might
cause brain tumors or cancer and then I
tried these and it was like undeniable I
love him like the minute you put them on
your ears and your phone's next to you
it connects which is the biggest problem
with anything Bluetooth that you're
going through your phone you're
resetting whatever the speakers or the
headphones and it doesn't connect right
away these connect right away they're
also noise canceling I fall asleep
sometimes listening to audiobooks on
planes I'll just put them on just to
cancel out any noise that's going around
they're so good I practice with them
for hours a day I'm at hotels like
listening to mixes it's this my car and
then just the speaker from my phone I've
never had a more honest headphone I
probably spend a few hours a day with
these
last essential is my phone
there's like an app that's like a
Metrodome so I practice to it all the
time like the Under Armor app I know how
far I run my favorite thing is just to
run and put on whatever new music's on
and be surprised or
like learn about something new there's a
piano app I can literally be in the
studio and while we start writing things
I can come up with other melodies or I
can listen and be like I want to add
this or find out what key it's in I love
that I love Shazam wherever I'm at in
the world I'm like what the [ __ ] is like
I want to know what song this is I also
just love taking photos on it like my
favorite photos some of my favorite
photos that I ever post it's just from
an iPhone there's this app
shout out Happy Cow it's the best
invention ever but it basically tells
you wherever you're at in the world what
vegan options you have within like
however many miles you want to choose
we've stumbled upon the most amazing
vegan restaurants through this app which
results in us being at dinner like
taking photos of of food 11th Madison in
New York Gautier in London it's a
Michelin rated restaurant that just went
vegan that wasn't plant-based before
Crossroads there's so many things I use
it for thank you guys for watching these
are my essentials
foreign
[Music]